Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I'm Benjamin Dixon
again for David while he is away.
Um, thanks for having me, David.
Let's talk about, uh, some breaking news from
last night.
Uh, the Internal Revenue Service.
This is, uh, according to, uh, the New York
Times, the original reporting was done by
the Washington Post.
But here's a quote from the New York Times
quote, the IRS, the internal revenue service
has no choice but to honor congressional requests
for president Trump's tax returns unless he
invokes a executive privilege to protect them
according to a draft legal memo written by
agency staff members.
Now, this is important because as you recall,
Steven Mnuchin, his excuse for not turning
over Donald Trump's tax returns to the committee
in Congress that clearly has the legal right
to, uh, to obtain anyone's tax returns for
that matter.
Um, minutian basically said that they did
not have the legislative purposes are legitimate
legislative pur, uh, purposes.
Uh, in fact, here's the quote saying, quote,
the memo appears to undercut the reasoning
offered by treasury secretary Steven, the
Newtons Minutian who has refused to comply
with the Democrats requests because they lack
a quote, legitimate legislative purpose.
Mr Mcgeechan said he made his decision after
consulting with lawyers from the Chez Department,
the IRS and the Justice Department.
Now here's why this matters.
He's claiming that he spoke to lawyers at
the IRS and here's a draft that is surfaced,
a draft memo that has surface that was written
last fall.
Uh, according to the Washington Post, uh,
it was never signed and never an official
memo.
Uh, and they are even, they are, they're already
giving a disclaimer saying that this particular
memo did not reach the desk of Steven Mnuchin.
However, if Steve Actually consulted with
the IRS attorneys, it's very likely they would
have come to the same conclusion or it's very
likely that they had access to that draft
memo.
And so this claim that he spoke that he's
making this decision to not turn over the
president's tax returns based on consulting
the IRS attorneys doesn't really hold a lot
of water.
Right?
It does become a, he said, she said kind of
gossipy type of thing.
But the bottom line is this, we're dealing
with an administration that has no regard
for checks and balances.
And not only are we dealing with the president,
I make the distinction of an administration
because it's clear that president Trump has
no respect for checks and balances.
He believes that he ought to be a dictator,
that he has the right to circumvent congress,
and that he has the authority and the ability
to use his bully pulpit to get his way.
That's one thing, but it becomes extreme.
It becomes even more dangerous when you have,
uh, collaborators that are inside of all the
different agencies because that's truly how
a dictatorship is actually implemented.
That's how authoritarianism actually is brought
to us.
It's not just by one demagoguing leader like
Donald Trump.
It's by those people throughout the layers
of the administration who are complicit like
Steven Mnuchin.
Like anyone who is, is, is bucking against,
um, the, these requests from Congress.
Um, you have the attorney general, did you
have others who are ignoring subpoenas, refusing
to testify before Congress?
I mean, they're literally looking at the checks
and balances system of our nation and basically
saying, just to hell with it, right?
There's no regard for it.
And that is extremely dangerous.
But that is where we have been for some time.
One of the things I remember most, uh, and
you probably remember the saying, um, immediately
after the election of Donald Trump, people
went on this tirade, uh, this, this tour rather,
um, saying to not let this become the new
normal or this can't become the new normal,
but the reality of it, this is the new normal.
And unless we figure out how to adjust and
to address this new normal, Donald Trump will
continue to get away with the things that
he gets away with.
And it does not help that we have democratic
leadership.
Nancy Polosi, Chuck Schumer who are timid
on using the power of impeachment, right?
That is literally their tool to put a person
who is, who has no regard for the constitution
and check Donald Trump has zero regard for
our norms, our institutions, but most importantly
the constitution of the United States.
And we have democratic leadership who are
afraid to actually do what they have to do
to protect our democracy such as it is.
That is where the danger really lies.
We have an authoritarian style dictator at
the top want to be dictator at the top.
You have, uh, people throughout the bureaucracies
who are complicit either with their silence
or they're active collaborators with the president.
And then you have an opposition party who
doesn't want to play opposition.
Or at least you have leadership in the opposition
party who, who simply do not want to fight
back.
This is the perfect recipe for a dictatorship
of full dictatorship for authoritarianism.
And Donald Trump is exactly the man to do
it.
As you can recall, uh, you may not recall,
but there was a video of, of p, of supporters
of Donald Trump.
And one of them literally said, uh, and if
I could find the clip out, play it.
But, but you could Google it.
And one of them literally said, I never thought
that I would want a dictator, but if I do,
but if we do have a dictator, I want it to
be Donald Trump.
So we have like this, we have all of the converging
forces necessary to usher in a dictatorship.
And I'm not saying that in terms of high of
scare tactics are, oh, hi, hyperbole.
We literally have the one system that can
place a check on the president of the United
States refusing to do so while you have the
president of the United States, his collaborators
and those are simply complicit with their
silence, ignoring the law, circumventing the
law, ignoring subpoenas, circumventing subpoenas.
And now we have a document from the IRS that
states that the president has to turn over
his tax returns to the congress.
And we have the leader of that department.
We have Steven Mnuchin, the secretary of the
Treasury who say, Oh, well, I talked to them,
but we came to the conclusion that Congress
had no legitimate legislative purpose in requesting
these documents.
When the president of the United States collaborators,
we have people who are complicit either, uh,
tacitly or directly.
And we have an opposition party led by two
Democrats, uh, Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
who refused to use their power to place a
check on this president who was clearly out
of control.